I'm to a tunnel by llola and this is
build your squad I have 15 dollars right
here I won't count them all they're all
in ones and I'm gonna choose from the
49ers and the end the Chiefs all the
time Super Bowl team I wanna have to go
with a Pat and put Pat as my quarterback
slash $3 with Pat mahomes I mean I I
kind of know Pat a little more personal
then then you know a lot of guys here
actually I know T oh pretty well too so
so that's seven dollars that's $12 Ronny
lots of the man ain't got no running
back though Jamaal Charles ain't got
what else I don't know I don't got a
linebacker huh going broke man you know
what I'll go Richard Sherman I got even
bought my money man and I only got five
selections I kind of know Pat mahomes
you know on a personal level I know Theo
on a personal level ronnie Lott I mean I
got to see him you know documentaries of
him growing up Jamaal Charles I mean
he's fast he got good relations - Pat
mahomes and Richard Sherman I mean you
see this guy playing playing football he
like since since you were like super
little I mean you've been with the
Seahawks Oh someone you admire I guess
so I'm talking about little this is my
squad and I'm here on behalf of auto
trader you know they've made car
shopping easier for me and my family as
well as Kelly Blue Book you know the
prices were just right for for me and my
family with us deciding on what car we
wanted to get you know and based off of
that I got my call it my first college
car it was a Jeep